when the Federal Reserve does
traditional open market open market
operations what they do is the Fed over
here will literally print money so it
prints money it doesn't necessarily have
to be cash it could be electronic money
and it uses that money to buy usually
short term Treasury securities in the
open market that's why it's called open
market operations so in exchange it gets
Treasury securities Treasuries now the
whole purpose of this it does increase
the demand for Treasuries and therefore
increase the price on Treasuries and
lower the interest rate but the main
point is is it takes us printed money
and it puts it in the banking system
because it buys Treasuries just from
people or from banks or institutions and
then those people take that cash that
they just got for these Treasuries and
they'll deposit it in banks so they'll
go and they'll deposit it in maybe Bank
1 over here then over here in bank 2 and
since there's more money in Bank 1 and
bank 2 you have the supply of money
going up supply going up and also the
demand for reserves is going up this
cash right here these are reserves
these are reserves so you have the
demand for reserves going down maybe
before this money entered the system
maybe bank 2 was running low on reserves
but now people have deposited money in
bank 2 so bank 2 doesn't need it as much
and so if you have the supply of money
going up you have the demand for money
going down or in particular I'm talking
about reserves I'm talking about base
money right over here then the overnight
borrowing rate between banks will go
down the price of money will go down and
that's what the federal funds rate is
it's the target rate so I'll say Fed
Funds funds rate it's the target rate
that the Fed sets for the overnight
borrowing of reserves between banks
that's the federal fund rate and it will
go down and that's how the Fed tries to
set the federal funds rate now
fast-forward to a situation like we are
right now
and the federal fund
rate is already at zero but the Fed
still wants to pump more money into the
economy and it wants to do it in a more
directed way so now what it's doing it's
still printing money but it's using that
money to buy other things it could buy
longer-term debt so it could buy longer
duration Treasuries longer so things
that are maybe going to maybe 10-year
Treasury bonds or further out than even
that or it could even buy completely
different assets it could maybe buy
mortgage-backed securities
mortgage-backed securities and the point
here isn't just to increase the money
supply the point in quantitative easing
is maybe to kind of smooth over what's
happening in certain parts of the market
so if they think that there's a log jam
in the mortgage-backed security market
that's why they're participating there
so this right over here that is
quantitative easing